you're in clark county election staff
are still counting ballots from election
day
they hope to finish that meticulous
process on time
even as the trump campaign fights the
results in court
hector mahia live this afternoon at the
election headquarters in clark county up
in north las vegas hector
we are told only a few thousand mail
ballots are left to get counted the
deadline to put those into the system is
thursday
we were talking about cured ballots and
those that needed an id verification
just under 2 000 ballots need to get
cured
that's for voters who did not sign or
whose signature did not match
any on record after that provisional
ballots about
60 000 of those will get sorted and
reviewed also
tomorrow is the last day for the
election department to accept anything
through the mail
just to give you an idea they're almost
done here's an idea of how much is left
this morning the u.s postal service
delivered only 24
ballots the trump team is making new
allegations that they have proof
of thousands of examples of what they
are calling voter irregularities
this includes the allegation that at
least two votes were cast
on behalf of dead people in clark county
however trump's team has yet to present
evidence that voter fraud happened on a
scale large enough to change election
results here in nevada
and here's the response from registrar
of voters joe gloria
we are finding explanations for
every challenge that they bring up any
uh
questions that they have related to the
integrity of what we're doing we have a
response
all we want to do is count votes all we
want to do is count votes
and the secretary i'm certain is going
to be vigorously going after anybody who
tried to test the system
in a tweet this morning state attorney
general aaron ford called the trump
campaign's attempt quote
a media blitz to discredit the election
he said that as of this morning an
official
complaint had not been yet filed through
his office and votes will get
certification
on monday november 16th and with this
being such a close election we asked
if any of the local candidates have
requested for a recount the registrar
voters here
told us that he does expect someone to
request a recount but
they have to wait until the vote canvas
is over to formally ask for one
that's the latest from north las vegas
hector mejia 8 news now